ça n'a pas d'autre objectif que
d'empêcher les journalistes de filmer
les fonctionnaires de police de diffuser
immédiatement les images notamment en
direct si là vous étiez en direct et qui
avait des policiers derrière moi vous ne
pourriez plus filmer est ce que les
journalistes pourront continuer à filmer
la réponse est oui pour aussi continuer
à diffuser la réponse est oui
est ce qu'un citoyen pour un film et
l'intervention de police la réponse est
oui
pourra t-il dénoncé au procureur de la
république la réponse est oui
mais pourra-t-on désormais faire des
appels ou vient le tour des policières
pour un taux fin des appels au meurtre
sur des policiers pour un taux demandé
que leurs femmes leurs enfants eux mêmes
lorsqu'ils ont au supermarché ou
lorsqu'ils rentrent chez eux comme ces
policiers de magnanville côté gorges et
égorgé madame la député de dole en fait
six heures parce qu'on les a reconnu
alors non et tant mieux car tic 24 soit
adoptée tout un débat en france au sujet
de ce projet de loi sur la sécurité
globale projet de loi qui prévoit
l'interdiction quiconque de films et de
diffuser des images de policiers en
fonction dans le bus qui soit porté
atteinte à son intégrité physique ou
psychique sous peine de sanctions
sévères même la prison mais ces images
sont parfois le seul moyen de dénoncer
des débordements des bavures policières
on n'a qu'à penser à la sphère
georgetown aux états unis ou aux
manifestations étudiantes lors du
printemps érable en 2012 au québec et
cette loi pourrait affecter le travail
de nos journalistes en france comme jean
françois bélanger lors de ces
manifestations des gilets jaunes en 2018
alors comment le gouvernement macron
justifie t-il ce projet de loi j'ai fait
le point avec jean philippe deniau
journaliste à france inter et chef du
service enquêtes justice et donc à
france inter et président de
l'association de la presse judiciaire
monsieur de new bonsoir bienvenue à
24,60 bonsoir merci beaucoup
enfin on vous joins au moment où un
grand débat en france sur la sécurité
c'est d'ailleurs un projet de loi qui
s'appelle loi sur la sécurité de la base
ça fait polémique dites nous pourquoi
particulièrement face à la liberté de
presse et d'expression
alors il y à l'intérieur de ce projet de
loi un article qui prévoit que le
diffusion d'image des visages ou
d'éléments d'identification des forces
de l'ordre ont donc policiers ou
gendarmes chez nous en france dans le
but de porter atteinte à son intégrité
physique ou psychique sera puni d'un an
de prison
en gros pour être plus clair et on
craint nous journalistes en france
qu'ils soient désormais interdit de
filmer des policiers en intervention
évidemment pour le gouvernement il
s'agit de selon la formule consacrée de
protéger ce qui nous protège et s'éteint
un but tout à fait louable mais on se
pose la question de savoir ce que
signifie une image qui portent atteinte
à l'intégrité physique d'un policier ou
d'une personne en général parce qu'on a
peut être témoins de violences
policières
on a pu aussi témoin de violence à
l'endroit des policiers on a tous à
l'esprit les légendes
on a l'exemple américain aussi ce sont
des images qui ont permis de révéler les
faits le fait des événements dans la
sphère notamment alors et quand on dit
dans l'article dans le but de porter
atteinte à l'intégrité physique et ça
dit qu'on ferait une exception du
travail journalistique comme le prétend
le ministre darmanin oui on a surtout
peur qu'en fait ce mois soit totalement
inutiles l'on a en france un droit sur
la presse qui est le très ancien
puisqu'il a été écrit en 1880 mais qui
est très riche d'une rue jurisprudence
constante qui s'adapte aux nécessités de
notre société aujourd'hui on peut être
condamné en france pour de la
diffamation pour de l'injure pour des
menaces pour de l'incitation à la haine
pour l'apologie de crime ou de
terrorisme donc on a déjà tout un
arsenal juridique pour n'importe quel
citoyen et en particulier un policier de
se plaindre du comportement d'un
journaliste par exemple qui porterait
atteinte à son intégrité en diffusant
des images de lui sur les réseaux
sociaux ou plus classiquement sur sur un
média ordinaire un média d'information
en général de porter plainte contre une
atteinte à son intégrité physique ça
existe déjà
jusqu'à maintenant de penser que vu
d'ici en tout cas votre gouvernement
veut défendre la liberté d'expression
est en train en plein procès dans la
sphère charlie hebdo le président macron
l'a réitérée à maintes reprises sa eu
des retentissements ici d'ailleurs sur
cette liberté d'expression et qu'en même
temps on veuille certains craignent que
ce projet de loi la restreignent
beaucoup whissell a restreint énormément
et c'est en fait un nouvel article de
loi qui s'inscrit dans une politique
depuis cinq ans la france a été
gravement touchée par de nombreux
attentats
nous avons une politique sécuritaire qui
s'est gravement renforcé en france et la
crise sanitaire également et ayant
apporté son lot de restriction petit à
petit on voit se crée dans notre pays
tout un arsenal juridique qui restreint
de plus en plus nos libertés et souvent
on se dit bon le gouvernement est
sérieux le gouvernement on peut lui
faire confiance aujourd'hui avec
n'abusera pas des lois qu'ils mettent en
place mais toutes ces lois vont
construire un arsenal qui va permettre
un jour on peut craindre le pire à
n'importe quel gouvernants qui n'aurait
pas les mêmes scrupules les mêmes
principes que ceux d'aujourd'hui
d'appliquer une politique totalement
restrictive des libertés individuelles
fondamentales du peuple et de la presse
en particulier alors amené cette
nationale dénonce le projet de loi vous
avez même l'appui de l'onu elle conseil
des droits de l'homme et pendant qu est
ce que vous croyez que le gouvernement
pourrait retraités là dessus c'est peu
probable ils ont très vraisemblablement
une majorité au parlement le texte va
certainement passer ce qui nous inquiète
beaucoup c'est l'interprétation du texte
évidemment sinon on regarde le texte tel
qu'il est écrit aujourd'hui on peut
supposer que un journaliste ne sera pas
arrêté uniquement parce qu'il filme
parce qu'il filme des policiers en
intervention
il faudra qu'il y ait une intention
malveillante mais rien n'empêchera par
exemple un policiers d'interpeller ou un
groupe de policiers d'interpeller à un
journaliste qui n'a pas d'intention
malveillante de le placer par exemple en
garde à vue ou en rétention et de le
relâcher une fois que la manifestation
ait terminé de l'empêcher de faire son
travail sans pour autant le poursuivre
ensuite voilà ce sont des jeunes ce sont
des dés c'est tout un arsenal qui permet
d'interpréter chaque action sur le
terrain il ya les journalistes puis
aussi les citoyens les manifestants que
lors de manifestations aussi en
profitent pour filmer des situations
plus litigieuses notamment sienne
échanges un peu plus
un peu plus corsé entre policiers et
manifestants parfois les gens révèle à
fil des événements qui sont importants
pour connaître la vérité absolument on a
eu plusieurs cas donc depuis deux ans
notamment avec les manifestations très
régulière des gilets jaunes en france on
a eu par exemple le cas d'un policier
qui avait lancé un pavé sur un
manifestant à un policier qui avait jeté
à terre en faisant un croche-pied un
suspect qui était pourtant déjà menotté
qui était tout à fait calmes
on a même eu un commissaire de police
qui a donné des coups de poing à une
personne qui était interpellé et
maîtrisé par ses collègues
ce sont des actes gratuits qui ont été
révélées effectivement par des vidéos
amateurs qui traînait par là j'allais
hier et qui ont permis grâce aux images
qui révélait le visage du policier qui
ont permis d'identifier le problème et
et de procéder dans ces trois cas à des
condamnations du policier en même temps
est-ce que j'ai pas vu cette image d'une
infirmière récemment qui protestaient
qui a fait un bras d'honneur à un doigt
d'honneur et qui quand on faisait on
rembobine un petit peu vous voyez
qu'elle avait lancé des pierres
policiers voilà alors la longue quête
n'est pas terminée sur sur ce cas là
mais effectivement ça existe mais dans
ce cas la loi actuelle sans cet article
24 cents ce nouvel article 24
la loi actuelle permet déjà de
poursuivre et éventuellement de
condamner cette personne très bien
monsieur de nous merci beaucoup on va
suivre avec intérêt ces lois puisqu'il
les a certainement des des
retentissements chez nous que chez nos
voisins également america merci beaucoup
merci au revoir